you
hi everyone it's Jerry Aman chess calm
and I just got paired up playing a
five-o game
so let's see what we get a Sicilian on
board let's go into an open Sicilian see
what kind of variation black throws at
me Dragon Knight or from Knight orphan
alright Bishop g5 Queen d2
preparing Queen side castles let's get
on with it and start throwing my my King
side pawns
black will be going King's side after
all
yeah let's get on with it start with f4
and if I back up there is Knight takes
e4
so I think right around now I'm prepared
to give up my bishop
yeah
maybe maybe f3 and g4 was another
approach we'll run with this though and
it have to the alternative again allowed
Knight takes e4 I was expecting night
Knight to c6 just throwing immediate
pressure on d4
so that move where do I want to go my
bishop I want to play g5 but if I do
that now I'd have to take like this cuz
my rook is unprotected so where to go to
my bishop just maybe e2
maybe I could take the night
bishop to eat and let's just go push a
bee to it's still a close eye on the
night reposition into c4 and I'm getting
the sense now that my opponent is going
to go Queen side after Bishop to d7 so
but even so this is the way forward and
maybe maybe Bishop g4 although this
useful move of King to be one is
probably better you know Queen side
let's get King be one in King be one in
the a3
often times if this is a maneuver for
the night to try to get into c4 you'll
want to delay the bishop moves so you
could take up the night in one move but
I had a clear plan in mind with quickly
trying to open things up on the
queenside
so throwing some heat on my be around my
d4 Knight I want to avoid a queen
exchange so let's play to b3 I have some
direct pressure now on the d6 pawn and
maybe even Knight a four into b6 is an
idea that's a very active move
can I make something like this work
that would be interesting or suppose I
even do something fancy like exchange
rooks Knight c5 now that just drops so
can i shoo this queen away she is a
pretty big bother
she's a bother okay maybe I'll give up
control of the age file and try to maybe
key in on these dark squares the bishop
won't be around to remedy yeah so that
let's see if let's see what uh what
black has in mind I I definitely want to
avoid a repetition but that's just a
little bit of a feeler just then and
with that said maybe now hmm let's put
the Bishop on f3 you know in this case
if Knight a5 III could just take out the
knight so I don't necessarily need that
my bishop on c4 at this stage and right
around now maybe just as a little bit of
a feeler we throw in Knight to a4 see
what the Queen wants to do and maybe
even Queen here I think I like this
smell of Queen here also if this that
drops the knight now that the bishop
isn't there and I'm putting pressure on
the rook in the corner
so maybe I could um take over control of
this file you know probably the brook
and my knife feels a little bit awkward
here for sure
can I just enter with my rook my queen
is defending the bishop feels active
let's do it
a little bit concerned about my night
getting trapped
how could I move forward what about a
five here yeah that feels that feels
pretty good let's uh let's open this up
and also keen on the c5 square they just
gave me controlled the c5 square my
bishop how can I move forward here 9c v
this move it's a little bit concerning
[Music]
chicks here
where are the tactics all right let's
try this move with the idea of having be
three on this this advance and realizing
that move a bit too late okay maybe be
five things are getting really really
sharp
really sharp
it's a really committal move if that
beef hon goes forward but this Queen b3
I think I'm entering
yeah this sharp position I have the
certainly the far more active rook
passive passive the Queen is the most
active piece right now but these two are
not so bad either Annika Bishop takes I
could consider taking with the Queen
because I am on the rook I do have a
flight square I like that
I'm also down a minute this game has
been flying by sharp position
keep our eyes open for tactics okay this
feels like it's should be winning for me
somehow smashing through on c6 Bishop
takes Knight is the threat I want to
avoid the Queen exchange I feel like I
should have some mating attack here
where are the unprotected pieces
take say six Bishop takes Knight feels
like this should be winning suppose
queen here I could take on a six
okay that is a check I don't have many
options let's go here Queen a5 trying to
defend simply drops the night
now this active piece feels a little bit
um well seems like she's not tied in so
well anymore
no I don't I don't feel like I'm
inconvenience let's say by the Queen
Queen III Queen b6
yeah she's just going back there but I
do have Bishop takes Knight at the very
least
Bishop takes Knight Bishop takes Knight
suppose I start with Knight takes b7
isn't that a close to a game ender
night before might be a move
now let's take care first get out of the
line of fire and now I'm prepared to me
Bishop takes b7 with Bishop takes Knight
all right let's do it I'm threatening
mate the Queen is dropping back I'm up a
pond let's let's take and maybe I am
completely fine with exchanging Queens
here
let's try it let's improve the King I'm
up upon I still have an active rook
maybe I want another pawn
sure does seem like it and also I'd be
defending my base point
my coat yeah they just resigned I
figured that they would test me because
I am NOT
I'm not quick I I don't have confidence
playing a bullet speed wise sometimes
here yeah a little bit of an early
resign I mean I am better here and I
okay well I guess I am going to be
picking up a second pond and there
really isn't a way forward for these
pieces in the end
wow what a sharp game the Sicilian
before I go over it with the computer
I didn't I don't believe I played this
right I think f4 is maybe not too good
maybe f3 and then and then go forward
with this kind of stuff is better
because on h6 I think this is a good
reply I have to take
there's otherwise the night sacrifices
on e4
this kind of stuff happens I take the
night they take here they're playing
with the bishop pair and they're up upon
I have a little bit of a lead in
development but yeah I wouldn't be fine
with this position I don't like it so
pretty much forced to do this and what
did I play g4 and black even has some
options to put a dent in my dark squares
you know g5 softening up the e5 square
but I thought something as simple as
knight c6 instead of the game of Bishop
e7 that struck me as a bit odd to pull
the bishop off of this diagonal because
you know I don't know that I even I
don't think I want to play g5 right now
I'm not threatening to do this because
one thing I certainly do not want to
have happen in this position is for the
e5 square to become a hole and that's
what would happen if I'm even doing a
move like g5 just to put on if Bishop d7
g5
well for one I'm helping this rook out
and you know it's not like you Black has
already committed the king so having an
open H files nice but this is really the
big point I do not want to give up the
e5 square the best piece for black would
be a knight but a bishop certainly
stands well and even in a position type
where it's much more simplified let's
say a major piece specific ending a
queen
or let's say no I don't have to get too
specific like that if if it's a
simplified a fairly simplified endgame
let's say major pieces in just a single
minor piece a queen she could take up a
very nice post on this e5 square so
let's uh let's dive in that's this is
really the main point of the the opening
stage at least I thought you know I mean
I'm in trouble
actually well not in trouble but I
thought knight c6 and then you know I
have to I have to back off and maybe
then b5
maybe even black still follows up with
this and prepares to go queenside but
the I thought that black really didn't
have to pull the bishop out for this
diagonal might as well wait for g5 to
hit before going to e7 anyhow let's uh
let me pull up the engine and we'll see
what more we can take away from this one
all righty let's go through this one
an open Sicilian on board
Bishop g5 move let's let's get to that
point real quick Queen d2
one I didn't even consider this I could
I could go in for
the structural damage try to play
against this try to try to make that be
six pawn flinch
try to weaken soften up the d5 square
somehow okay that's an alternative
i queenside castle Bishop e7 and yeah
he wants to go with f3 so on f4 what
does it have to say about f4 ok I could
still go with f4 and I do need to take
the night here just confirming if I drop
back there is in fact Knight takes e4
yes Knight takes e4 Knight takes e4
Bishop takes Bishop yeah ok so important
tactic to be familiar with if I take
that night out now ok g4 h4 hmm
I'm taking a pause right here just for a
moment because
I just saw a pop-up g4 and h4 and I'm
just trying to figure out the difference
between the two I mean it may very well
be the case that they both get played
and the move order does not matter but
I'm trying to mmm reason out what is
maybe the less committal move but
probably the less committal move is h4
with this earlier talk of weakening the
e5 square if I play g4 black can already
think about making my f4 pawn flinch
and that would granted the e5 square
to the black pieces but you don't get
that with at least at this moment right
here with h4
I always have a g3 pawn that can
reinforce f4 and as a result reinforce
'if I've so I'm being very technical
right here but maybe I would be leaning
more towards h4 before g4 if I could do
it over again I'm not sure how much it
really matters in the end
anyhow I went with g4
and I was pointing out I thought knight
c6 right here
hmm it even suggests this other reply
Knight to f3 I was I was intending
III I guess it's okay with that
huh notice the suggestion here g5r so
noticing a difference here between the
two posts with the night
it does already like g54 black however
maybe I make black think a little bit
more about playing g5 by keeping my
knight in this key section of the board
these key 16 squares where it is
optimally placed and you know it fights
against this g5 advance it may still be
good for black you know there is
compensation I imagine giving up upon
like this an open file and the e5 square
and the position is opening up for the
two bishops but there is at least now
some cost connected with g5 with the
knight on f3 compared to b3
okay well in the end the bishop
voluntarily
just went back to e7 I get on with h4
Bishop e2 it popped up for a second King
b1 AK I went with Bishop to e2
Bishop d7 a3 I was thinking a3 right
around now but I think maybe those are
king b1 a3 figured I've said g4 h for
let's get on with that final push g5
breaking open the queenside black is
there just in time to queenside castle
you know if the bishop was still on CA
in this position black would have a a
difficult decision capture me and give
me complete control over the only open
file the H file or move the rook to a
passive post you know but black is there
just in time to queenside castle no just
a hair of a pull point three ish for me
so wants to go with the knight takes
yeah maybe maybe getting one more minor
piece off playing with this small pond
Center exchange a night put the bishop
on c6 as an improvement for black g6
I popped up for a moment rook to h6 this
is not something I considered now that's
interesting
rook to h6 and the event of a capture I
get a passed pawn in black maybe a
little bit offside with the Queen you
know maybe that's such an easy task and
trying to hunt down that past Age pawn
okay that's something to know a rook h6
move out with something more standard I
guess a little air for my king Queen b6
and now Knight f3 yeah I was pretty much
locked into this night on b3 move what
is it with this I wonder what what's
making me think more about Knight be
three instead of Knight f3 maybe the
security of the night having a pond
supporting it and he's still over near
the Kings side hmm
I mean I'm used to this as a if like an
e5 move or much earlier on in the game a
knight b3 reaction but you'll have to
keep this moving in mind as well it's
clearly popping up in multiple
variations now
okay well in the end I III can't be so
bad
queen f2
do I have something here rook h2f fun
okay that's the move I played and the
Queen simply goes back well what I do
have queen bee to what I have in mind I
always think I was leaning towards
Knight a four oh no no no no I wasn't
leaning towards that I was saying it
during the game I was going to try to
key in on these dark squares Queen to e3
it does like and quite a lot I would say
this is a significant advantage now
close to a pawn and a half
so yeah we repeat it a little bit what
could I have done better here because I
definitely don't want to do some type of
back and forth queen queen to d3 my
first impression is what is that even
doing what kind of an improvement is
that for the Queen
to say I don't know I'm not sure okay
h1 and in the end we didn't have that
repeat
now I wants Bishop f3 likes Bishop f3
Bishop g4 as well
and yeah that's this Bishop f3 was just
to stop a repeat of Queen 2 f2
day four it's a fan of
back to a seven Bishop g4 Knight c3 this
is where I played what queen c3 is it
okay with that
not really
hmm okay it's not a losing move or
anything but there's certainly a shift
there it wants to capture Bishop takes
hmm I wouldn't have gone with Bishop
takes I would have captured with the
rook now apparently e5 is strong
huh
yeah that certainly breaks down my
little pond chain here and likes to
activate that dark square bishop okay
well that wasn't that would have been an
interesting turn of events an
interesting way to change the structure
for sure to try and put that x-factor
bishop into action what did black do
okay they they did go with that and then
played queen f2 so the the better reply
here is to follow up with e5
okay black played Queen f2 it's still
okay with that and now I get my chance
to play e5 yeah this is where this is
where I play d5
no I activated my rook first it even it
suggests once more 'if I've so this was
something we both overlooked the a
changing of the structure only after
rook to f8 I played a five and now it is
a fan of my position just by a hair
d5 and now this is probably where I made
uh yes the longest thing I jumped in
with my be Knights
I think it's extremely important which
Knight you go with a knight to d4 ooh
that would have been a a big shock to me
if Knight to d4 is played I'm giving up
the d4 square by going with this Knight
the issue I saw with going with the
other night is d4 I thought at least I
could just scoot over to d3 I was
thinking if I do this then I'm losing
stuff it's a take and then take on f3 or
excuse me just take the Queen
here I can't even take back okay well
apparently going with either night to c5
is just not good I should be going with
Queen to d3 I don't mean to keep moving
like that I'm left clicking or right
clicking and it's making the move okay
t5i jump in black has an opportunity for
night to d4 here and after this push
Queen b3 Queen f1 check ah Queen f1 and
then maybe Queen to b5 training a queen
exchange and then my Knights or maybe a
little bit clumsy Queen f1 King a to
Queen B five to try and defend yeah and
then Bishop to e4
tough game what was played Queenie one
and I guess after that I'm winning
yeah King a to the Queen drops back to
try and defend but no I did find the
correct sequence here first taking on b7
and then c6 taking here allows Bishop
takes Knight still better for me but not
as convincing okay
did not mean to go that far back
Knight takes b7 his best bishop takes
and only now take on c6
Queen c7 and in this endgame I am up
upon and now my king
it's kind of weird how that happened
this is how he emerges into this his
endgame you can see four and you know
I'm up upon it is plus three I upon
resign at this stage I will be picking
up another one and really the biggest
thing is that there's just no counter
play for black material plus and even if
somehow there is pressure on f4 my rook
once he captures on f7 is there to
defend f4 sharp game I certainly as you
could tell learned a lot from these
different suggestions the computer was
throwing my way hopefully you were able
to take something away from this one as
well feel free as usual so leave any
feedback in the comment section below
and I will catch you in the next video
hope you're having a great day take care
bye
you